um
is is there anything with erica that
that you've applied
that you might have learned from working
with megan yeah like i said mo
communication like you know what i'm
saying like with me and erica
we like i wasn't taking the chance no
more with that [ __ ] we
moved us straight to you know i'm saying
houston moved in
like we got more close to molding it in
and just so well
you know uh we won't have to have you
know if she feeling bad about something
or don't like something
you could come say it to me you know
what i'm saying you ain't gotta like
plot with the manager
and then you know y'all scheming against
me because i'm this bad guy that want to
do
something harm to you you know and um so
pretty much just like
communication and you know cause because
you know
what she said when they came in they
said that everybody was saying
this contract was so bad but the first
thing she said was hey we want that
megan contract
i was like all right 60 40.
yeah i mean yeah no but i wanted to just
show a point like you know what i'm
saying you was telling us we gave you
this bad contract man people coming in
here just
like it's almost bad that it's public
because now that's the first thing
people are asking about you know
do you take what happened personally
against megan do you think it was more
the t faire's character see the only
reason why you know you all you saw the
spats between me and megan is because
you know
you know of course she like to say
little smart stuff because she want
everybody to think she like tough you
know that's stubborn but you know we
know the real
so it's like we're gonna say something
back we all from texas too we're not
gonna let you talk
and say stuff and then we're not gonna
say nothing back especially when we know
we didn't do nothing wrong to you but
never had an issue with megan you know
what i'm saying we almost got our
business wrapped up i won't have no
issues with her then
it's you know what i'm saying i just
hate that you know
the t ferris guy i keep coming back to
that you know i moved this guy into my
house
you know for a whole year he was living
with me and we were all just doing this
stuff for him to
cross us up like that and he understood
when i came home i told him i had a plan
the plan was to build houston culture
back up
you know what i'm saying and keep doing
it it wasn't just the fun making you
know so
for when they did that it was like they
closed the doors on the city for a
little bit you know what i'm talking
about because you get all that work to
open them doors back
up and bam y'all just